probably not supposed to tell us how to
tell tales out of school about him
but the one of the only sex addicts i've
ever known in my life
like legit sex addict where he had to
put it aside and not [ __ ] for a long
time because he was like
he he [ __ ] a lot it fascinated me when
he told me that what do you mean a sex
addict and he was like i used to [ __ ]
nine ten times a day wow well now now
you've met two more sex addicts because
uh did you go in wait like yeah to a
program i i did i did an intensive
outpatient sex addict rehab are you
[ __ ] i swear to god what is the
difference between i like sex and i need
help i mean it's like compulsive
compulsive sex that causes shame
is that right
see that i've never i've never it's
never been a shame when i've had sex but
a [ __ ] celebration so i've never felt
that but my friend malcolm um is a bear
in toronto and he like just
he he was like at one point he was like
you got daddy told me he was gay he's
like you gotta [ __ ] go bear if you
want bear you get so [ __ ] man he's
like no no hot directors except peter
jackson and he lost the weight and [ __ ]
so malcolm has always been selling me on
it and whatnot but malcolm told me
always trying he's like you've never
leave your wife man you could make like
a [ __ ] bear bandit but he has one of
those apps growler grinder
i've got the grinder app
he's he
lived on that app and was like having
sex four or five times a day
and he said he felt that yeah that's
shame it was a foreign notion of me
where i'm like how could you like you
should feel fortunate blessed but he was
just like you just get to a place where
it is absolutely
meaningless it's like
it's like drinking coors light all day
who knew that that was [ __ ] possible
except you [ __ ] too right that's what
your podcast should be about that's
[ __ ]
cockblock what does that mean excuse me
first off i'm gonna
revise scott's definition of of
addiction conviction in general as it
applies to any form of addiction is
continued behavior despite consequences
when something is [ __ ] up your life
but you keep doing it anyway and you
can't stop doing it because you have
this disease of addiction um so to where
i
met scott
his brother and i his brother's also a
double winner as we speak
i wish i knew any of these people right
a double winner meaning um
someone who's made it into um two
different 12-step fellowships is that
right for addiction double black belt
right and um so that was how i met scott
through his brother when i came out of
my
sex addict rehab i
had a bunch of tour dates
on my schedule and i was like i'm a dead
duck you know especially because after
every show so wait you're saying he was
your sober living companion what would
you call it cockpit
you know
that's how i met dieker okay deker was
jay's slp
his sober living pal
when he was in rehab and they let him
out for like you could go to comic-con
for two days but you got to take a sober
living companion with slc's i think
they're called we always called them
sober living pal so deeker was jay's
sober living pal forever and then that's
how we we met in the beginning so you
were that for sex yeah yeah
so when you're the sober living pal for
sex so you're like don't [ __ ] her i'll
jerk you off
i'll take the bullet
yeah i'm a good friend
we would share like a hotel room so like
there's no going back to the you know
bringing chicks back or whatever and
what does one feel like
you know i'm i'm not a i like food but
not to the place where well i guess i
have like liked food to the place where
it was complicated because i had a
[ __ ] heart attack i almost died so i
guess i too am an addict but um i i've
never
i the way i understand it because i've
known jason forever he's addict addict
takes one addiction away has to
substitute it with another behavior so
if you take away sex what do you
substitute it with food
so you tend to gain weight when you go
to like sex rehab i just lost 30 pounds
after a sex yeah
and you're like you know how i lost it
right
a little yeah it it can become a little
bit of a
whack-a-mole where you address one thing
and another issue pops up
and um
you know i don't know that it's as
simple as saying uh you just replace the
behavior i mean like the whole concept
of 12 step is uh
you know sort of adopting a spiritual
approach to life and and uh service to
others and you know helping people and
now can i ask this question of course
when you were using or whatever you were
addicted to did you not feel those ways
in general like i think i know it means
you're selfish because you're like i
want to do things but even i know hi
[ __ ] people they're always trying to
help others out and [ __ ] like that
they're always thinking of their fellow
man after they're fixed up i think i was
generally
uh
pretty
good guy you know i wasn't you know i
like towards the end of my run with
drugs and alcohol i developed uh
an ability to be quite mean-spirited um
you know i i became kind of a nasty
person
but
being addicted does not necessarily mean
you're a horrible person it's just that
the nature of addiction just makes you
you know like
when your only priority is to to keep
getting your fix
it's it's a selfish dynamic and and uh
it's a spiritual approach that let me
ask you this because we are uh cut from
a similar cloth
you are yourself for a living yeah
correct you wouldn't argue that right i
started as a filmmaker but i slowly
became myself for a living
now
i can't speak for you but
i
my favorite thing in the world to do
possibly even more than [ __ ]
is be myself for a living because it's
just a mind [ __ ] where it's just like
i'm i wake up and i'm on the job like
that that's [ __ ] fantastic
could that ever be an addiction
absolutely is that right yeah i mean uh
you're supposed to say no you mean you
mean fame or not so much fame but like
i like i
i use uh
uh
my professional life to escape all
manner of [ __ ] a lot of people online
you know over the course of the
president's trump presidency were like
[ __ ] ah and [ __ ] like that i i'm not
that person if something pisses me off
i'm like i'm just gonna go right
rather because there's some [ __ ] you
cannot do anything about right and
in that way it's like well i can't shape
this world
i'm gonna go shape
my world i could definitely do that as
have you look at this we're in a [ __ ]
van recording podcast so you have shaped
your world is there a place
where
that's possibly too much could that ever
be an addiction i
i think so um
but
i think that like you got to eat right
you got to make a living right in in the
past like before uh i got clean and
sober with drugs and alcohol i had no
ability to to like turn it off i was
just ah crazy all the time i was just a
hundred percent you know this wild guy
and i really identified as the persona
of stevo and i was just crazy all the
time
and
i think that
what's dangerous whether it's an
addiction or not we can leave that aside
but what's dangerous is the idea of
being
identified with uh with this persona and
and having your self-worth
uh
derived from your value as a commodity
in the entertainment industry that would
be that would be mine right you might
have just nailed it on the head down
it's a dangerous it's a dangerous
dynamic because when you're commodifying
yourself and then you're right you're
you are
only as good to yourself or as valuable
you feel as you are to the world so if
you're not a part of the conversation
right you're on a slippery slope
when you derive your self-esteem from
being in the spotlight
then uh
i think that one way or another the
spotlight will
you know it'll shine elsewhere and even
if it's on you that's potentially
scarier because because what about you
know like our bodies deteriorate we
don't be you know that's the scariest
thing for me because i'm at my core just
an attention [ __ ] from the front from
adam out of the womb an attention look
at me look at me were you a class clown
sure big time right and not even good at
it you know i think all of my behavior
just alienated my peers but
i noticed you i did they didn't they did
and and it occurs to me that in our
society
like i i would bet that if you surveyed
100 people that was that that
uh
there a lot of people would not know
what the definition of the word hospice
is
i say that i think that's important
because
everybody knows what a hospital is
because you go to the hospital to get
better but the idea of a hospice being
somewhere where you go and you don't get
better you go and die people don't want
to think about that
you know and people don't even want to
deal with elderly people it's like being
old in itself is a party foul yeah they
think you want they just want to stuff
you away in a nursing home they don't
even want to look at you because you
serve as a reminder of everyone
yeah yeah and so but yet our job is to
distract from that of course that's like
our main function in life is be like
and for a few seconds [ __ ]
for a few seconds [ __ ] looking
at us
has forgotten right the ultimate truth
which is like i'm bound for a hospice
one dude 100 did this is shaping up to
be a fascinating conversation because i
couldn't agree with you more
i i really couldn't now being an
attention [ __ ] and recognizing that
that
elderly
people are walking party valves that
nobody wants to pay attention to
it's like
now oh wait a second yeah there's an
expiration date on this [ __ ] right
that's so that's so scary walking party
foul well here's where what people are
isn't it isn't it
isn't it evolution though
you know you began life as um
an attention [ __ ] yep and
undoubtedly
got a lot of attention yep so when one
seeks and one finds and gets that
ameliorates what drove one in the first
place you gotta grow
so
i don't i i think you could be
older i don't think you'll ever be old
like what the traditional but i think
you'd be older and still hold a cool
ledge i submit to you george carlin man
was [ __ ] cool until the moment he was
guys still cool now he's been dead like
[ __ ] 10 years
and he was old yeah i submit another one
stan lee old as [ __ ] he was old from the
moment i knew him when they brought him
to mall rats they told us be careful
this man's 76 he could go at any minute
he lived another 20 years and the man
who said that to me that he could go at
any minute died way before stan lee
well i i i think you'll maintain
i think you'll be live the you will
redefine the silver fox well thank you i
appreciate the kind words greatly i i do
believe that uh as i've already
uh kind of proven that i'm able to
evolve absolutely you know and and i
think that i will have my own approach
when i get bummed out about the idea of
being middle aged or elderly i think man
you know like i'm gonna be
these ages
like in a fashion that nobody's ever
done before young man you get to
recreate it right if you look at a thing
and you're like i don't like how that
thing is you've spent your whole life
changing that right so why would this be
any [ __ ] different you'll get to
redefine age and people will be like
well that's a way to do it right
and then they'll invite the old man to
the party he won't be a party foul right
he'll be a party plus yeah i love that
and and going back to
what i was saying about how i couldn't
turn it off yeah
when i didn't
because dude i was a [ __ ] disaster it
was it was it was gnarly it got
you're very jason museum yeah yes very
good you guys are very much of the same
cloth it got it got ugly especially i
think jason muse was a little bit more
like isolating isolated he was more
behind closed doors and you would have
to eventually he got to that point
because once he got to like the
harder stuff once he was to heroin
that's not like hey who wants to hang
out and do heroin like you want to talk
about depressing people yeah
you took him to the mall and he had to
stay with you you guys were walking
around that was uh literally
i was a sober living companion before i
knew that you can get paid for that sort
of thing
[ __ ] oh yeah absolutely but yeah it's
he
he was a guy who would eventually be by
himself you seem like a party guy that
was like in the midst of it all i put
together a
mailing list of uh 200 of the most
influential people who uh whose contact
info i had and barraged them around the
clock 24 hours a day with my downward
spiral
sharing it
and a cautionary tale for sure
for sure
and then getting sober i kind of
identified like oh wow you know there's
this like
you know like the path that i was on
wasn't
headed anywhere good
so i really need to
find some separation between the persona
of stevo and then like whoever i am as a
person you know who now
when you think
you know like uh there's a
episode of
batman the animated series
when um he met uh the mad hatter and the
mad hatter like you know he didn't know
most of the episode he was in a dream
and at the end he [ __ ] figures it out
that he's in a dream and [ __ ]
and so like alfred i think it is you
know the coda of the episode is just
like how did you
figure it out and he goes because in the
dream that
that hatter was creating for me
i was bruce wayne
and he was like but when i really dream
i'd dream as batman so he knew he's like
this is fake this is unreal who do you
dream as do you dream as the persona or
do you dream as the kid yeah what a
great question
and is there a difference between the
two yeah
there's a leather it blends a lot i
would say a dream not as the persona
but what's interesting is that
the dream [ __ ] right
yeah i think what's interesting is that
um
you know as the more
like mindful i was to
sort of establish an identity separate
from the persona
um
and and to really like pay attention to
uh to all of this like spiritual
practice the better i got at managing
the persona you know like the reality
was when i couldn't turn it off when i
was just [ __ ] nuts all day long
i was not [ __ ] good at being stevo i
was not good at managing the business of
stephen i was not good at uh cleverly
strategically mapping out a game plan
and and in sobriety
uh i i've taken away a lot of
distractions i've taken away a lot of
handicaps and i've i've become more and
more
just laser focused on what i want to
accomplish and i've been really [ __ ]
productive and and god is kind of good
at it how long you got now 14 years of
chemical sobriety five years of sexual
sobriety and now i'm uh like in in the
food deal my latest run with uh
food is i'm
about 70 days of taking a photo of every
single meal before i eat it and sending
it to my mentor in the food program what
is that about what do you mean i just
got so gnarly out of control with sugar
i don't even look as much like a guy i
have lost a lot of weight over the last
70 days you have never occurred to me
right as anything but a thin person wow
but dude like we'll leave a comedy club
at night and he'll get like you know two
brownies with ice cream on it and like
why why would you do that
it's just compulsive behavior
is it to compound the joy like you're
coming off the stage and you're like
holy [ __ ] i rocked it
the adrenaline high everyone in this
room [ __ ] loves me what would make
this better
sex booze drugs food for me it's food
it's just like
i i like i do hollywood babylon with
ralph and we have for like
12 years we used to do it at uh
uh the improv all the time now we're
flappers and burbank with ralph ralph
garmin is a friend of mine he used to be
on k rock okay yeah yeah okay and the
morning show
the the kevin and bean show so him and
i've been doing this podcast called
hollywood babylon for like 12 years it's
a total like nightclub show it's real
fun and [ __ ] but
when the show is done
like ralph hangs out at the bar and
drinks and and not not like
problematically just he enjoys that and
hangs out with people and [ __ ] like that
i get in the car and i
come home
and traditionally it was always like now
i'm gonna go to my office
and like eat because
i did good i deserve this i was very
much and still am and we'll fight for
ever being a rewards eater okay and it
feels like your rewards everything i
mean i think yeah like i did it i'm
gonna throw this on top but i think uh
in addiction it's like if you're if
you're bummed out you know like you you
soothe yourself with with your reward
you know whatever the the comfort
seeking behavior is when is it okay
though when is it just allowed to be a
good thing and not i think
i think
what addiction does come down to is like
you know being addicted to shame
and i think like that's the kind of
bottom
line is like
that would you core belief about
yourself and like feeling shitty and so
you're doing things that make you feel
shitty and then like you know it's
self-fulfilling there's a lot of that is
that based on brene brown someone
telling you like
hey you're bad or do you just feel bad i
think like growing up like thinking
you're bad or doing whatever you kind of
like were told as a kid and then in your
subconscious it kind of sticks around so
you seek out those behaviors that like
for example this is an extreme version
of it but some kid
um i knew was born in a dumpster
so he thought he was a piece of [ __ ]
the [ __ ] so he would do he would like
sexually do things that like would make
him feel like a piece of [ __ ] how do you
get born in a dumpster homeless have fun
it's like a homeless lady wow his mom
was homeless and she
i mean look
that's close to the jesus story right
born in a manger you know that's not a
cool place to be born but the sad thing
is the
that it haunted him for the rest of his
life something he had no control over
right yeah but he was like well you know
he was pissed off at god and he's like
you know maybe i am a piece of [ __ ] i
was born in a trash can and then like so
you know
that evolved into like just toxic
behaviors that you carry out later
because it kind of matches up with your
core belief what you think about
yourself right i think it's also
a little bit
um
erroneous to try to make logic of
addiction too you know like you you
can't like always it's true you can't
always figure out the origin of it it's
not like a direct abc correlation yeah
my my my sponsor always says it doesn't
matter how the jackass got into the
ditch just get it out
right for sure it doesn't matter what
started the fire put the [ __ ] fire
out right like i think that clip was
awesome but not as awesome as my new
book a hard kick in the nuts what i've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions which is out september 27th
and if you pre-order it right now you
can get the autographed copy so get on
it man pre-order my book it's not going
to waste your time because i'm proven
dude new york times best seller my first
book's five star rated on amazon and i
have no doubt this one will be two so
get the autographed copy right now by
pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude